president trump putting america first
front and center during a rousing
commencement address at the u.s
naval academy graduation and this comes
as more new developments unfold over the
north korea summit
but before we get to that let's hear the
president's message to the class of 2018
stressing the importance of our
military's might
we are witnessing the great reawakening
of the american spirit and of american
might
we have rediscovered our identity
we gained our stride
and we're proud again yes they're
respecting us
again yes america is back
the best way to prevent war
is to be fully prepared for war
if a fight must come there is no
other alternative victory
winning beautiful words to the class of
2018
i do say strive for excellence
live for adventure think big dream
bigger
push further sell faster fly higher
and never ever stop reaching for
greatness
and meanwhile the president is leaving
the door open to rescheduling the
canceled summit with north korea's kim
jong-un
this after the rogue regime says they're
still willing to meet with trump
at any time we're going to see what
happens we're talking to them now
it was a very nice statement they put
out we'll see what happens we'll see
what happens it could even be the 12th
we're talking to them now they very much
want to do it
we'd like to do it we're going to see
what happens
okay greg so giving a rousing speech
were you prepared for that you seem
stunned well i'm trying to figure out
what i should talk about should i talk
about north korea or that amazing
commencement speech finally a
commencement speech for the rest of
america
i'll talk about that the interesting
thing about trump is that he's speaking
a language that
everyone around the world understands
including our adversary so when he say
it says stuff
that that is conveying america first and
we're back and we're great it's kind of
meant for
russia it's meant for china it's meant
for north it's meant for everybody and
who
actually understands it and i know that
it works because it
upsets the elites who prefer the you
know the flaccid lexicon of of the
of the typical you know political
platitudes that he doesn't traffic in
so i think the rest of the world gets it
even if morning joe doesn't
and uh he's hijacked the bull horn he's
like you know
before hollywood was what transmitted
our values around the world
and it seems like he's kind of taking
the bull horn and says nope my turn
okay there you go right and gutfelt show
gets it
candy show gets it waterfold show gets
it just not morning show
all right so what do you think about
this a great speech yes america first
very rousing was well received very well
received apparently he
spent hours afterwards shaking hands
with all the cadets he really really
loves these people in uniform
he has a special relationship with the
us military he's funding them
to heights that we've never seen before
to build faster planes and
faster ships and more massive nuclear
warheads one
so the american military is back he
recognizes it and
i think it's it's nice for the country
to see a president
who 100 percent supports the men and
women
in the military he said something which
was very smart you want to build the
military up so strongly that you never
have to use it and i think that's
the message there when it comes to north
korea it's classic like you said
yesterday art of the deal
he's moving he's shaking he's ziggy
zagging and the whole time the peanut
gallery is trying to
throw spit balls at him and just wait 24
hours
and north korea comes begging back to
the table and it looks like they're more
desperate to sit down with the president
than he is
to sit down with them so he clearly has
the upper hand and
like we said we'll wait and see we'll
wait and see what happens in singapore
all right there you go kennedy hello
hi there uh it's it's a really funny
contrast with hillary clinton because
these are two vastly different speeches
and this may be the only high-profile
speech a conservative gives
at a college commencement this year and
of course at the military academy
annapolis
the president is not going to be heckled
and that also has to be refreshing it is
a hand-picked
venue and receptive audience but these
speeches are so different because
hillary clinton just a week ago
at yale was screeching to a very bored
audience i'm still not
over it and the president is able to
give a more forward-looking speech
whether or not
you agree with some of the principles
that he
addresses and talks about and yes you're
absolutely right instead of talking
about himself
and a painful loss and reliving
groundhog day every single
day he is telegraphing to north korea
and russia
and china and also gets to talk a little
bit about
his agenda so you know i didn't think we
were going to be talking at all
this year about a commencement speech
that wasn't completely
bubble wrapped in group think and for
that
it is somewhat refreshing you know a lot
of people enjoyed this one i hope you
did too
no to me is to come and listen to you
guys and you know there are protesters
outside a couple protesters i don't
think a whole lot but people standing
there those are for you one
okay and then inside the kids were
pretty respectful but that was about it
but you guys call it rousing i'm
interested
but let me just say this speech was
about
america first it was wrapped in
patriotism he wrapped himself in the
flag he wrapped himself in the military
i think that's jesse why he spent time
he wants them and their stamp of
approval and their high approval ratings
among the american people to transfer to
him
but when you think he's giving a rousing
patriotic speech because he wants to
boost his approval rating yes
maybe he's just proud of the country and
wants to
let's look at address let's look at the
substance of it when he talks about
oh we're going to make the military
stronger and all wait a minute our
military is the strongest in the world
when we're going to make it even
stronger he suggests that somehow
somebody didn't believe in them who
didn't believe in the military
obama bush clinton who didn't believe
the last president
oh please he's running funded under
president obama the nobel peace prize
guy but every day he was in office
let me just tell you something that is
an echo in the conservative chamber but
the fact is
we have a military that is funded at 20
i think the top
20 other militaries in the world don't
have as much funding as our military
okay
but but juan let me agree with you on
something i i do think that we spend
an awful lot of money on the military
and i do think when we talk about
responsible stewardship
there are ways that we could look at
cutting costs in the military without
making our country less safe
and without uh compromising our
patriotism and
the the debt of gratitude that we owe to
men and women who wear the uniform
but also being supportive of the
military doesn't just mean writing them
a blank check
i agree but can i just respond to one
you're
when you question somebody's patriotism
that means you can read their mind if
somebody's actually
expressing a love for a country you can
say oh that's just
you know he's trying to play to this
audience but you don't know that
you don't know that so what you're doing
is act it's not an art it's not an
argument
to say that you're claiming that you you
can read his mind right that he's not
yes yeah you did you basically said it
was all an act he's wrapping up
he was wrapping himself in the flag
himself in the flesh
maybe he loves america when you're
reading his mind when you're saying
when you're saying oh he's rapping
you're basically saying i know what he's
really doing no greg
i listen to the speech the man is
talking america first right he's saying
no more apologies right he's saying we
are going to look out for america first
how does this hurt around the world it's
not mind reading it's
listening okay and what he said was
you're interpreting
guys let me speak for a second okay
so what did the rest of the world hear
oh america's interests are no longer
as america as a global leader he is
retrenching he's pulling back he's
saying we're going to look out for our
interests first
and somehow missing the idea that
america is supposed to
be a world president of the united
states of america
he's not president of north korea or
right but we are involved there because
we have interest in asia totally but why
can't he
look at america first and say what can i
do to improve the conditions
every day of hard-working men and women
of the military that serve valiantly by
making sure that they're taken care of
by making improvements in the va
looking inward to be able to figure out
things and make it better for everybody
across the country
makes us stronger better as a nation and
better able but isn't that one of the
arguments of the anti-war
left that president trump has embraced
that we have spent so much money
overseas
we have needlessly spent trillions of
dollars in the middle east
why shouldn't we be investing it here
that's something that you would hear
elizabeth
or bernie sanders say the president is
essentially saying that you can't have
it both ways
what he what he is saying to the world
is i'm going to pull out of agreements
like the iran deal or the climate deal
or asia deal
in terms of markets because i'm going to
renegotiate i'm a deal maker
and i'm going to create some chaos here
but what is the rest of the world here
uh gee you're no longer part of our
effort
and the united states is seeding its
role as a world leader which is to me
last time i checked we're still number
one one
and one and apparent in everything and
if if you want to be america last
that's fine nobody's saying this is an
america first strategy
and we have not left our allies behind
because we just rallied a coalition in
asia
we rallied a coalition in syria we just
got unanimous
uh council support for the u.n over
north korea there's a lot of things
we're doing
leading the world instead of going along
to get along like other presidents is
that
printing those coins that have trump and
kim on them he's a big investor
yes i am all the way to the bank i mean
you're buying them up you brought it you
brought up two deals that were
uh i mean that were correct decisions if
you talk about the climate deal would
have cost 100 trillion
over a century so it was good to pull
out of that iran we know
we know that ben rhodes was so bad he
had a lie about this deal to america
right we now know that it's bad
the third thing that's going on right
now is north korea people are acting
like oh my god this is shocking this is
shocking that that
that he canceled at first it's like you
must be shocked by the sunrise
this is how negotiations go and what's
interesting to me is seeing the media
kind of happy if world peace might hit a
snag
because they dislike trump so much to
them trump is not a president he's your
bitter
no he's your ex that you're bitter about
so if your ex
suddenly discovers a cure for a disease
you can't be happy
even though it solves a huge problem
because he's your ex oh that's very
childish
and do that have to be happy when the
disease is
here yes yes thank you jesse one more
thing no i mean i was just going to say
in terms of allies the
president obama left the iraqis behind
he left the ukrainians behind
and the israelis behind so if you want
to talk about alliances
did you notice who just won the election
in iraq what about libya who's that
anti-american clerical maybe your
how about that you know this is the
thing if i'm going to get you a
subscription to a newspaper i really am